les sciences avec la mise sur orbite
d'un télescope géant pour explorer
l'origine de l'univers la nasa a lancé
l'engin aujourd'hui avec succès julia
delage lancement parfait ce matin pour
search ou le nouveau télescope de la
nasa
sa mission dans l'espace photographiée
ce qui est invisible grâce à
l'infrarouge
sous cette lumière les traces de pattes
de ce char est voyante
même quand il disparaît le télescope de
la nasa va utiliser le même principe
à gauche une galaxie photographier avec
un télescope classique
à droite la même chose mais en
infrarouge des terres jusqu'à l'heure
inconnus vont être perceptible
on arrive à voir avec l'infrarouge à
travers la poussière donc arriver à voir
vraiment le coeur de la formation de ce
système planétaire
et puis il se trouve aussi que dans
l'infrarouge le contraste entre les
planètes et puis l'étoile va être
augmentée voir enfin ce qui n'a jamais
pu être observé pour comprendre comment
voilà 15 milliards d'années la première
étincelle est née
c'est la mission de sorte qu y restera
cinq ans dans l'espace